hey 42 here the earth is 4.6 billion
years old
if we scale that down to say 46 years
humans have been here for only four
hours our Industrial Revolution began
one minute ago and in that time we have
destroyed more than 50% of the world's
forests welcome to RIF
a priest saved a four-year-old boy from
drowning that boy was named Adolf Hitler
all the humans on earth could fit into
one cubic mile goats have rectangular
pupils a small percentage of static on
televisions is actually radioactive
resonance from the Big Bang thirteen
billion years ago if there were no space
between any of its atoms earth will be
the size of a baseball turtles can
breathe out of their butts the loneliest
tree in the world was hit by a drunk
driver it's in the Sahara Desert and is
the only tree for 400 kilometers in any
direction butterflies eat each other and
therefore are color balls and finally
just months before 9/11 the World Trade
Centers lease was privatized and sold to
Larry Silverstein
silverstein took out an insurance plan
that covered terrorism after 9/11
silverstein took the insurance company
to court claiming he should be paid
double because there were two attacks he
won and was awarded four billion five
hundred and fifty million dollars thanks
for the view subscribe for more 42